light in the gloom of lockdown two new
covet vaccines
both effective against new variants of
the virus and there are millions of
doses on order
the more people will get it the sooner
we get rid of this
i think yeah the only hope we have is
vaccine
and if not 100 they will be effective at
least 95
or so the more the better really so the
more that we can produce and the more
that they can work for everyone and
protect against the new strains
then definitely the better all for it
the new vaccine made by johnson and
johnson
is the first to prove effective with
just one dose
clinical trials showed it protected
two-thirds of people against moderate or
severe covid
we observed that across all the
different regions and especially in the
very sick
it prevented very sick but also
prevented against debt and
hospitalization
and that is what makes this pandemic so
particular and so severe for the
population
and we're very happy to say that with a
single dose we can reach
this a second vaccine made by novavax
is the first to be based on the actual
spike protein from the virus
and it packs a punch it protected almost
90 percent of people in trials in the uk
and south africa even though new
variants of the virus were spreading
rapidly
it was of concern because we were very
aware that the
cases that were occurring in particular
in the last month were largely
of the the variant we didn't know until
the the trial um outcome
uh showed that it it has really made
little difference to the efficacy of the
vaccine
so really important because we now have
a vaccine we know is effective against
the uk variant
and we can be even more confident about
deploying this vaccine in the uk
the two new jabs could bring an extra 90
million doses to accelerate the uk's
vaccine rollout over the coming months
60 million from novavax to be
manufactured in stockton on teas
and 30 million from johnson johnson this
adds to our existing 157 million doses
from the three vaccines that have
already been approved
and the new vaccines will be easy to
store and distribute
both can be kept at fridge temperature
if the medical regulator does approve
these two new vaccines then britain
could have far
more doses than it actually needs but
some vaccines may prove better
preventing disease in the elderly others
are preventing spread of the virus in
the young
it could be a pick and mix future and
britain has plenty of choice
but there are no guarantees the new
vaccines can be scaled up easily
to meet demand not just from the uk but
worldwide
you might be able to find that you can
make something really well in a small
quantity in a jam jar
but as soon as you start actually trying
to make this in
you know thousand liter vats you get
other things actually taking place
which which you know um don't happen at
the small scale
but start to happen at the larger scale
we're talking about a brand new
technology here
and with brand new technologies there
can be
teething problems the prime minister has
hailed the results from the clinical
trials as very encouraging
if the vaccines are approved doses
should start arriving
in vaccination clinics in the summer
thomas more sky news